welcome to to the session and to my talk
I'm going to talk about provenance and
which can be used for reproduce data
without the tropics I'm covering in this
talk is under slide I talked about the
concept of provenance data multiple
provenance how to model provenance data
but api's are web available for python
can be like called provenance from
applications and store problems in
database it's the kind of topic not
necessarily necessarily in disorder
actually so as an introduction about me
- degree in industrial mathematics and
from Germany I'm Brooke wasn't so dry
and signal intelligent where I came in
contact the term of the thing like data
science we were doing like classifying
radar signals and all this kind of stuff
and I was working in the US and the idea
the National Lab next Chicago and today
I'm working at a German Aerospace Center
it's similar like the NASA and the US
but a bit smaller a bit well but
basically we do the same stuff I have to
load sir I'm reading a department for
intelligence with systems in Cologne and
Berlin Germany and I'm leading a group
of these surgical procedures of
engineering in Jena Germany it's also
cover another company for medical health
apps where I'm mostly the patient but
also like the data scientist and today
but the topic of my talk is about
reproducibility so currently in the like
scientific world
some say the island their producer
bility crisis half if not impossible to
reproduce
besides that you have cut in some way
and a lot of tools and strategies
metrology is to prevent that to actually
enable you to
reduce your sight so for example in data
science or in general science this might
be oh and reproducibility means one
thing is you can reduce your own results
by yourself or other people are able to
we would have reduce your sights which
is especially important in science and
you can do things like public source
code as open source software just use
open source software you should like do
good standards and software engineering
for example code reviews use code
repositories in sciences nowadays kind
of standard in most cases that you if
you're writing a paper and make a
publication just publish the source code
- also you can use container for [ __ ]
which contains um execution environment
such as doctor and other technologies
you can also lose workflows not just
enter commands by hand and don't be able
to repeat things you can use notebooks
electronic laboratory notebooks to
record all your things or to write down
all those things and make notes about
things that you've been doing you can
use open data formats and of course the
data management system for your data and
one important topic is to to take care
and to record metadata of the data that
you have and the provenance of your data
and that's the main topic of stifling
slides what is metadata and provenance
as your might now data files in data
processing they have two parts the
actual data may be measured or simulated
resides or generated by some other
process and the metadata that which
belongs to the data information that
describes the data or relates the data
to some other piece of data and so on
metadata can include depending on your
application domain very very different
thing
for example geographic information where
you can do spatial search or so quality
information also if you have data which
is which has been measured by some
instruments then maybe the settings of
the instrument or the status of the
instrument and of course metadata from
the site system from the files cells
side size check some dates when the
pipes change and so on and of course
providing information and this is this
is the information about the source of
the data or the information and just
implies the process which led to the
existence of piece of data this is
actually some kind of basic definition
of of the problems and this is
interesting or useful for information to
understand where the data is coming from
or I mean to be most specific where
piece of a data file is coming from and
well of course there are other terms or
related terms traceability language are
two terms which often are synonyms for
problems some people also when you talk
about information about the history of
them some people also mentioned logging
but we would see what this is different
than provenance lots of monitoring your
model monitoring information is some
kind of information is useful for
socially for running systems but it's
not the province but especially logging
information and monitoring information
is very useful to generate actually
province data provenance information and
provenance information it includes I
mean if you want to do this you want to
have the provenance of information you
can capture it archive it distributes
information and this is the source of
all data site that comes into your
environment
from but whatever sauce the source of
the algorithms that you are using can be
part of the programs also like things
like specification documents about the
algorithms or data processing software
of course description of your processing
environment such people reproduce the
steps edge of 10g process environment is
is important also information about the
framework or other kind of software that
you used to do data processing and of
course records of your stock executions
and especially in data science so
traditional high performance computing
is more only on the left side by us like
very few and very large machines where
you put your coat on and they doing
heavy processing for days and weeks on
like thousands of processors but very
homogeneous machines as technologies
like MPI message passing interface or
giving these posters and threats and you
today it's more especially in data
science it's moving into a distributed
computing way of more implicit control
to specific computation graphs or
something with technologies like Hadoop
and more like spark and dark and
especially in this world it's even more
complicated to to get an overview of
what happens and what kind of hardware
was involved in your your vocals and the
workflows can be well very large that
are complicated and in each domain very
different so this is one of the workers
that we using for analyzing satellite
images you cannot read compact clear
contactors with internet and but this is
the typical size of an workflow for for
geo data processing in our in our
research left
and so you can imagine it's hard to get
an overview of what happened here from
these kind of doctors so I'm not coming
to more more formal definition of
provenance because you can wake up to
problems in very different ways and so
can stages the others is specification
by the WS received word for vacuum
consortium is also like doing things
like standardizing HTML and all this
kind of web stuff and the semantics that
part of the HWC came up the
specification for the recommendation for
for provenance and the definition and
the document was prevalent as
information about entities activities
and people who are involved in producing
the piece of data or thing and the
information then can be used to assess
to make assessment about the quality you
are reliability or trust versus of the
data it's likely definition the
specification from the w3c contains a
lot of sub specifications for for
certain aspects in this context for
example an ontology data module
specification notation for humans
constraints and cover of other stuff and
not go into any of these details now but
the basic concept in this Providence
model and this Poland standard is it's
got 12 a key three things entities
entities are physical or digital or
conceptual things for example documents
files websites graphics any kind of data
set we have activities activities yeah
activities generate new entities
why did our activities use entities for
example and process and algorithm uses
some piece of data improves the new
piece of data and you have agents what
actions can take some role in to the
activity and have some kind of
responsibility and that three important
agents actually wants are persons like
let us in the room a piece of software
as an agent for examples of a framework
or an app or whatever and an
organization is an activity so these are
three basic elements of the problem
style prop and another important aspect
of our GD relations between these basic
elements and for example this is also
very different like compared to logging
by us like a single log entry and
recently locks Uyghurs is not related to
some other entry in the problems word
every element is related to some other
element this was really important the
kind of relate relations are well
defined actually for example you can see
the entity was derived from the system
relation to itself generally an entity
is derived from another entity some kind
of data was processed and produced a new
piece of data or an entity was generated
by another by an activity it means the
piece of data was generated by some kind
of others on I go I only used an entity
and I wasn't used a file or something
and also the agent is related to the
entities for example an entity belongs
was attributed to an agent and also the
activity was associated with an agent
for example an agent like the user
started in process or started and I
wasn't do something
this is the basic data model of the prof
standard and there's this data model you
can specify the provenance of your of
your application of your domain and if
you want to explain this
not to your colleagues but for example
to your parents or grandparents you can
use this this example the prevalence of
a piece of a cake of baking a cake
actually so recording the progress of
the process usually you write it from or
you read it from the bottom to the top
for example we want to have the
provenance of a piece of a cake and the
cake actually was generated by a process
by an activity which is called bake or
baking and baking used a couple of
entities at our extruder floor and
actually the cake was derived from all
these ingredients it's a very basic
example very basic provenance graph and
in this graph actually there's no agent
butters can imagine what an agent is and
the problem this kind of programs comes
with one kind of notation for problems
other annotations are like textual
representations for provenance there are
couple of file formats that are being
used for example you profe n format is
specified by the w3c you can see it here
the text format which can read or years
as a JSON format or from semantic
networks to other format or as XML
format for that all all of them are used
in vice kinds of applications and you
can have visualizations the most simple
kind of visualization is just drawing a
graph like this like we saw in the the
baking server and you you read it from
the bottom to the top I mean this
example shows the provenance of a
graphic of a go
line graph yeah and to actually add
problems according to the application is
from the conceptual excited
straightforward very simple it's just
like logging you just every application
and store information about it in a
Providence database or problem store
very easy at this level and the kind of
problem storage can have for the kind of
technologies for strong this kind of
stuff is the evolved variety of
possibilities that you have depends on
the application on and on requirements
or example performance requirements and
the size of the domain the provenance
data for example really huge large
projects who record ecords problems use
today relational database and it's great
for crowing or you can use XML or RDF
for strong this kind of stuff or or what
we are using mostly graph databases for
storing problems because provenance
graph graphs actually and there are a
couple of services based on you in
Westville api's or there's one thing if
you want to happen really in soft start
and physically start for storing
provenance formation JSON in that
application called posture from
University of Sao Sentinel in grade
button where you can just there is an
API they can send provenance information
provenance document and making publicly
available or stored privately if you
have an account and they have API is in
Python jQuery for your JavaScript world
and they also have simple visualization
so I think it's a friend of timer it
show you an example later
and as I said provenance information are
graphs actually directed acyclic graphs
there are no loops that nor serpents and
as you can see here the graph on the on
the tight side you really firmly top and
to the bottom from the bottom to the top
for example is the provenance of an
entity called reliant it was generated
by an activity and this activity used
another entity was so generated by
another activity and so on and what is
it activities and and eggs and entities
belong to to certain users this we kind
of span at visualization of provenance
data and yeah because provenance is
current Providence RI directed exit the
glass the natural database for strong
currents our graph databases the tons of
them actually some our pure database
just as new for a or others are like
multi validating databases like around
ODB but also commercial and open source
versions of all these kind of databases
and a long ways to state applies usually
they are querying languages which you
can use to make queries on this store to
ask in the database for example new for
J is an open source version that we're
using in some projects implemented in
Java stores property glass key value
based address and it's just available
for download and store only provenance
graph in the graph databases will really
straightforward to just it Maps just
choose a property graph model of the
graph database and then you can make
queries for example oil relations
between entities and agents in the in
this case this - crowing
and this is also used for doing analysis
on the provenance data and current
information the special cases that we
are working on convey is the feud of
trusted problems because sometimes in
some applications the provenance
information should be used or must be
used to like to really prove in a legal
sense that result is correct or that the
process was correct that has been
applied and we are using only a
blockchain to store the provenance
information daughter blockchain is a
graph basically of data linked linked
linked data structure and you just can
map provenance graph to obtain database
to actually gather adrenalode provenance
also it's the same you have a couple of
possibilities and this is really what
gets complicated the data model for
problem is easy the general architecture
is also easy but to gather problem
information from you
application can be really hard depending
on your application and if you have
access to the application if you accept
to the source code to the execution
environment two things are important if
you have to policy allows you to access
certain kinds of information for example
in a couple of industrial use case that
we are working on in this with a bus or
with other manufacturers the Provident
information is much more important and
hopefully send the extra data because it
tells you everything about the design
process of certain things and so this is
really truthful whether you can
instrument the codes or not but that in
general you have a couple of
possibilities you can record provenance
at one time of the application
into things like an instrumentation on
source code level it's sometimes not
very nice its software engineering
perspective because you have to add some
piece of extra code tree application
often it's committed combined with
combined with this logging office
produce such as X aspect-oriented
programming then you have to chance to
add problems according to your
application on compile time of
strategies like this use like dependency
alien versions of your code and then add
some some code into it during compile
time which was split out some problem
deformation that you can use not very
much not lot many applications use this
strategy because it does not work very
well so and in case where you can don't
have access to the development
environment or the source code you can
do a special perspective from recording
of problems or generating improvement
looking at the things that you have and
try to try to figure out what can you
use for recording or for reconstruction
or constructing the province of your
process for example information in terms
of height system metadata and so on and
true practically incorporate province
recording into your applications maybe
for Python there couple of libraries
that you can use for pyonium for DES and
so on also they are yeah
many tools getting more and more tools
which supports you somehow to generate
problems for example a python library
prof some optionally also developed from
the university of south central in
england in general is to to equity
provenance is very easy doesn't stress
the extra code possibly extra code that
you have to add to your application for
example open a new provenance document
and then add all the all the entities or
the elements like entities and agents
and well there is no new process that is
important for the problems for example
an entity an agent and the relations
between the entities or agents and
processes and with this kind of
information this information through
this simple provenance graph which
produces actually a simple action HTML
file you can also use libraries like
puff neo4j for storing the provenance
documents directly into it like a graph
database very straightforward then you
have the provenance graph is in a graph
database so it's very easy in a sense I
wanted to show the smaller something
as I said instrumentation that you can
do it on the source code level for
example what we are using was adding
extra code for province so calling into
for like demonstration purposes into
into a repeater notebook for example
notebook which basically uses pandas and
natural lip to do something this data
introduced graphic and we added the
provenance related elements here's like
the entities for example video ecology
runs off he used libraries for pandas
the net profit for example we also
record information about the agent in
this case the user that is doing
something and for example in this
we had information about the activity
that is being performed in the code and
this is this is kind of programming and
executing it you can so she was out of
this Jupiter notebook is some kind of
graphics which is actually like my
weight data and yeah I see and you can
get the problems class yeah there's
another program profitable connector and
as a result or they're currently doing
is the kind of instrumentation of
tensorflow is a slightly used to machine
learning for example and our goal is
there to like understand more deeply
what is happening during training phases
50/50 training lab success is simple in
this example from the sink only tons of
flow tutorial and if you're doing like
we have instrumented it and met it
through the problems burdened and for
like 400 training iterations to be able
to get huge amount of data in the graph
database and we province databases
64,000 bit data base notes is a lot of
activities and entities and if you have
this you can do also like analysis of
the data in the database for example all
the shortest paths from from the latest
iteration to the initial operation in
your pins of flow graph and other fancy
stuff I'm saving this one because
learning out of time one important thing
one interesting thing is you can also
record province of your source code for
example if you are using get get a
positive lesson as in that application
get ripped off they can just enter a
pass to get repository and it generates
a problems document provenance graph out
of it
these programs graph our this is really
oh this is actually the problem to have
a really really small program this
provenance graphs will become really
large so and the examinee verification
that are shown from the university of
simply cannot generate a graphic anymore
out of it
so say going into memory hours and this
literally the lake the lab topic of the
top problem tooth validation this is a
point which is really not clearly at the
end this is there's a lot of research
going on and this topics for example
especially if you want to to communicate
they put the information in the province
data to other people non expert like
thermos problems or people usually like
normal people don't understand the
provenance graphs
especially enjoyed by yourself are not
able to understand anymore of these
graphs becoming very large for example
in the medical domain we are trying
things like generating comic strips out
of this province graphs where it
actually shows pictures of zroll the
data side of your life actually yeah so
Mikey Masterson summary record with
problems of data or data sensory loss is
important to understand actually whether
data is coming from and to reproduce or
the results or the old workflows and if
you do so you should really use the
standard for problems like each w3c
standard which is met easy
nepeta to a graph database and allows
easy querying and if you have all throat
information using the same data model
the same standard you can compare it and
doing other things and there Tyson Foods
right so that was actually my talk but
before crank of questions one
announcement
I'm also organizing a workshop - high
performance computing if you
have to write papers for your work if
you want written need to have
publications you can submit papers
through scientific work Rockville Rock
Shop Python 5 performance and scientific
computing we actually seventh
incarnation this year
always co-located this is supercomputing
conference in November and this will
happen now in November 1st 2017 in
Denver Colorado this year theta
thanks thank you very much I will we've
got about 35 minutes for questions try
pass the microphone around so you are
referring to a block chain example there
can you expand on that little bit Oh
what what you are saying in one of your
slides there was a block chain example
yes can you expand on that a little bit
ready basically it's very easy we we
produce the mapping between the the
provenance graph to the to the data
structure in the block chain and then
yes witness reliable restores the
travelers car facility block train
making all the connections as if you at
you LMS to G provenance graph then
listen in addition to the block chain
and then it's some kind of I mean you
can not really change it without making
other people aware that you change to
doctrine that's actually basic the basic
outcome that you want to have if if you
manipulate two prominent data we want to
be aware of it or to make if we want to
make it impossible so I have a question
how do you encourage people to actually
use this because it seems like it needs
extra work for people and not many
people are willing to do that so can you
comment on that how to encourage people
to be more reproducible and do these
things so the easels easier thing is
people need the answers that can come
out of problems and if they understand
it
that they can get the answers for
example what I'll make maybe a deep
analysis what are the data sources for a
piece of data for example and data based
entry if you want to understand what
what kind of sensors at the very
beginning was was influencing my piece
of data and for example they want to
have like assumptions or information
about the quality of the data then you
can use the provenance and if people
understand that they are willing to
incorporate this kind of technology into
the applications okay thank you again
great session
[Applause]